le processus électoral canadien soulève
on dirait quelques inquiétudes puisque
une délégation de l'organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération en europe la
bce et au canada pour assister justement
au processus électoral qui mène à ce
scrutin du 19 octobre
fabriquer ce que c'est pas un peu
surprenant c'est pas à chaque élection à
laquelle l'ouest et envoie des bisous
observateurs et si vous avez raison
c'est lille en fait c'est la première
fois qu'une délégation vient au canada
depuis 2006 ce dernier en 2006 avait
pris quelques petites notes en disant il
ya peut-être des choses à améliorer
alors cette fois ci c'est donc six
délégués qui vont se promener pendant
deux semaines majoritairement ottawa
aller faire un petit tour à toronto
également à winnipeg ne faut pas
s'attendre à ce qu'ils aillent visiter
ce qui se passe dans les dix neuf mille
bureaux soit parce qu'il sait juste six
personnes donc il a qui viennent du
royaume uni pays bas oui en plus
regardées assez assez éclectique comme
représentation au royaume-uni etats-unis
bulgarie slovénie croatie et mongolie
tout ça juste pour deux semaines alors
c'est pas exceptionnel
le canada déjà participé à des missions
d'observation par exemple en ukraine en
2014 est actuellement mais une
délégation est en cours de terminer
finalement son processus d'observation
au bélarus où là on a vraiment eu un
régime présidentiel qui s'étaient réunis
pour une cinquième fois donc là on pense
que tout n'a pas forcément été très
respectée au niveau de la démocratie
dont il y aura un rapport qui va être
produit dans plusieurs semaines
ben justement le canada n'est pas une
nouvelle démocratie quand même
alors qu'est ce qui motive cette visite
plus précisément mais d'abord que je
vous l'avais dit il a pris quelques
notes il ya huit ans déjà maintenant dix
ans il faudrait améliorer certaines
choses on a parlé mon reportage ici de
laurent terrière donkey la fameuse loi
sur l'intégrité des élections qui
étaient votés certains diront sans
grande consultation par les
conservateurs en 2014 et donc ce qu'ils
veulent vérifier un peu c est ce que le
financement des partis se fait toujours
de bonne façon
est-ce que la représentativité des
minorités comme les autochtones les
femmes ou d'autres personnes sont
vraiment bien représenté dans le système
politique également les processus
d'identification des électeurs est ce
que ça vient pas justement limiter
l'accès à certaines personnes par
exemple comme les autochtones et puis
surtout on va vérifier les pratiques
douteuses rappelez vous les robes encore
les fameux appel automatique qui
induisent en erreur certains électeurs
donc on veut s'assurer que ça ne se
passera pas lors de cette élection si
rapport dans huit semaines à suivre donc
merci avec